well over the past week the 8 news ly
team has told you the hundreds of
traffic cameras all across the valley do
not record from backups on i-15 at the
state line to crashes that tangle our
commutes it seems we're always showing
you traffic cameras and somewhere
somewhere someone somewhere that is make
sure
we can do that and now traffic anchor
nate tannenbaum is taking you inside the
command center
well there are several someones keeping
their eyes on hundreds of rtc traffic
cameras all over southern nevada 24 7
and they do so much more
including the folks at the regional
transportation commission do a great job
of putting messages on the overhead
signs
i call there frequently fast traffic
operations conan hey carter nathan
tottenham asking about crashes from the
nevada state police highway patrol
website there's this crash up at uh 95
at rancho if you pull up camera two two
two on a visit to the fast traffic
operations conan demarco walked me
through just some of the many things
they do so this is an incident from
earlier once they zero in on a crash
they can send out text alerts there's a
crash on i-15 south of
diamond it just popped up on my phone
here it is
a crash on i-15 northbound south of blue
diamond on the right shoulder hey
trooper laurel how you doing they may
take a call from a state trooper asking
to turn on the overhead sign at a
truckway station so the weigh stations
opened but the sign wasn't accurate yep
exactly and you'll see the beacon is on
and then you'll see the commercial
vehicles and they're going oh boy we
better go
actually show up on those overhead signs
do not text
and
drive
and there you have your message
all right i'll take five seconds off of
four or eight a traffic technician might
call in wanting to tweak the timing of a
signal light you can bring up every
traffic signal in this valley almost
exactly but of all that the fast folks
do conan says amber alerts are among the
most important we get reports all the
time from different police agencies
we want to help out as much as we can
and the best way to do it is to post
messages for motorists it could mean
the life of
one person you know
maybe if i get another shot at working
with conan they'll let me put a
different message on one of those
overhead signs buckle up drive carefully
put down that phone
thanks to conan all his co-workers as
well as the head of fast theresa gaicer
everyone at the rtc for their help on
this story and with the traffic every
day
nathan todendum live local now